bonsoir bien dans ses 7,8 l'aktu du
mardi 15 avril à les ressortissants
algériens appelés aux urnes pour élire
leur prochain président dans les
yvelines quatre bureaux de vote sont à
la disposition des électeurs à poissy et
mantes la jolie à versailles et attrapes
comme vous le voyez sur ces images à la
maison des familles rue jean zay attrape
la commune compte environ 3500 inscrits
pour ces élections présidentielles et le
taux de participation s'élève ici pour
le moment à plus de 30%
six candidats se présentent dont le
président sortant abdelaziz bouteflika
rachid ouali responsable du bureau de
vote au micro de yolaine thorez
les élections seront closes le 17 avril
à 19 heures nous votons un jury les gens
savent ce que c'est que voter c'est en
même temps un droit mais c'est en même
temps un devoir civique
ce qui nous a satisfaits cette fois ci
c'est que beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
jeunes se sont rendus dans les urnes
voilà on va tout va changer de sujet
maintenant on va parler d'un
anniversaire 150 ans et pour en parler
d'eux invités en plateau qui n'ont pas
150 ans l'anniversaire de la croix-rouge
et envies de l'islam bonsoir mon simone
président de la croix rousse de 50 ans
divine de taille et aux michaud bonsoir
je marque directeur local du secourisme
et de l'urgence jeudi la croix-rouge à
150 ans est une vieille dame n'est
toujours d'actualité et pour cette
actualité
la croix rouge de saint quentin organise
une exposition qui se déroule en ce
moment jusqu'à vendredi en mairie
d'elancourt alors d'abord un petit mot
sur une histoire de la croix rouge par
qui at elle été créée la croix rouge
était qu'il arrive pas pour ceux qui ne
savent pas là par henri dunant qui avait
un rendez vous et napoléon iii et kid
s'est donc trouvée devoir visiter de
traverser la bataille de solférino le
champ de bataille
ea qui a été un peu choqué de voir tous
ces hommes blessés aux mourants et suite
à ça il ça l'a amené à réagir aux
immédiatement pour s'occuper des blessés
mais ensuite à mettre en place ce qui a
été la première convention de genève en
1864 que qui a été également l'acte
fondateur de la croix-rouge puisqu'en
même temps on mettait en place des
sociétés nationales dans chaque pays il
faut penser pas rouge convention de
genève c'est croix rouge
pas forcément non c'est bon je ne savais
pas avant d'entrain de croix rouge non
plus donc très franchement
enfin nous justement de ce symbole de la
croix rouge drapeau suisse alors pour
ceux qui auront l'oeil
voilà pour ceux qui auront là il voit là
c'est le négatif du drapeau suisse
audace et une croix blanche sur un
drapeau rouge est long on a choisi pour
garder l'idée de la neutralité de la
suisse qui est qu'un des éléments
particulièrement important de la
politique de la croix rouge
on a pris le négatif donc ça ne devenait
une croix rouge sur un drapeau blanc
néanmoins pour éviter de choquer
quelques niveaux que ce soit chaque pays
a le droit de choisir un emblème qui est
différent il y en a trois emblèmes
lacroix ou le croit sambre où le cristal
rouge pour les pays qui veulent ni de la
croix ni du croissant depuis
d'accord demi ou deux noms de 2300 je ne
connaissais pas donc ce sont des actions
qui sont internationale mais qui sont
aussi sur un plan local c'est
internationale parce que la croix rouge
compte 90 millions de personnes qui
porte cet uniforme c'est important la
croix 90 millions de personnes c'est une
fois et demie la population française
c'est pour ça que ta croix rouge est
relativement connu et que c'est une si
on parle en termes de marketing une
marque particulièrement diffusée mais en
fait c'est vrai que peu de personne
hormis des actions internationales où on
nous voit régulièrement mais souvent
c'est à la fois international et local
parce que c'est toujours la corde locale
qui finalement garde la main sur les
actions qui sont à faire localement
local de 50 ans ni vous combien de
bénévoles dont le nombre d'heures de
bénévolat surtout vont être offerts en
2013 parce que ça c'est un chiffre qui
en dit long je sais par exemple oui ce
chiffre qui marque beaucoup et on a fait
27 mille heures de volontariat dont
vingt-deux mille heures de bénévolat que
la différence c'est que nous avons des
jeunes en service civique qui
donc une petite rémunération puisque
c'est un service civique dont qu'on a
fait on a voulu garder la distinction
puisqu'il ya une forme de rémunération
qui était versée là on n'a pas voulu
mélanger les deux ânes de 1000 heures de
bénévolat
gratuit le lion de la fois gratuitement
de te fais depuis 27 meilleurs avec un
peu de volonté les 5000 heures de
volontariat avec des services civiques
voilà d'accord quels types de missions
vous venez apprendre à laisser la parole
à nyon parce que voilà oui oui voilà
parce que c'est un d une des chevilles
ouvrières important de notre délégation
locale alors sur le local on a nos
actions sociales qui sont finalement
relativement connu que ce soit nos deux
épiceries sociales celles de trappes ou
celle des encours c'est notre
vestiboutique à montigny c'est notre
accueil pour aider des gens qui ont des
problèmes lors quel que soit le problème
ça va de remplir les documents à obtenir
un microcrédit obtenir éventuellement un
logement ou une domiciliation puisque
nous faisons de la domiciliation depuis
depuis quelques mois maintenant ça va
plus loin que l'aide alimentaire ou
vestimentaire
oui oui ça va on essaie d'aider tous les
niveaux possibles imaginables donc on a
aussi notre halte répit pour malades
d'alzheimer
donc on essaie de lutter contre toute
forme d'exclusion quelle quelle qu'elle
soit et sous quelque forme qu'elle
puisse se présenter ni on va vous vous
êtes à la croix rouge depuis combien de
temps ces trois ans et demi qu'est ce
qui vous a donné envie d'intégrer cette
institution qui a 150 ans alors ce qu'on
marquait ce qui m'a ce qui a été le cas
pour moi c'est qu'au début on rentre à
la croix rouge en se disant j'y vais
pour une action
juste parce qu'on en a une petite idée
est que plus on est dedans plus on se
rend compte que l'association est
importante plus il ya d'activité et on
se retrouve avec des personnes qui font
une multitude d'activités
on a une idée c'est à dire qu'on a eu
l'idée peut-être la part où je ne fais
que ça et on se rend compte que vous
écoutez jean luc istin effectivement
tout à fait donc des premières images
qu'on a qu'on fait du recrutement c'est
les personnes qui nous disent on a la
vision de ce qu'on voit à la télé quand
il ya une urgence humanitaire allait de
l'aide internationale
quelquefois on oui on vous voit sur des
postes de secours sur des gros
dispositifs comme les férias ce genre de
choses est en fait en en parlant avec
les gens et on s'aperçoit qu'il y en ait
beaucoup plus présent que ça quand on
voit nos niveaux de l'urgence et du
secourisme
on est quand même présent sur toutes les
yvelines sur des postes départementaux
comme la fête des loges le paris
versailles de paris mantes sur des
postes locaux surtout qu'elles auront
justement sur ces alors le rôle du coup
la croix rouge sur le port de la croix
rouge c'est d'être un maillon de la
chaîne de secours est d'être là de façon
préventive pour pouvoir assurer la
sécurité
le dispositif la manifestation qui est
sur place qui est mise en place par
l'association la mairie peu importe mais
nous notre rôle c'est d'avoir de pouvoir
assurer la couverture sanitaire du
dispositif
donc on est là de façon à être présente
de faire les premiers soins les premiers
secours et ensuite on passe le relais
soit en demander une équipe de pompiers
de venir par le biais du samu soir on
fait les transporte directement à
l'hôpital ça dépend du type de
dispositif qu'on a mais ça va jusqu aux
dispositifs comme le stade de france on
va en renfort comme rock en seine où les
gros les gros événements vous avez sur
une formation pour faire ça parce que
tout le monde peut rentrer bénévoles à
la croire aux entreprises une petite
formation gros organismes de formation
ce qu'on ne sait pas ce que j'ai appris
aussi en étudiant les 150 ans de la
croix rouge c'est que c'est la croix
rouge qui a créé les premières écoles
d'ambulancière c'est la croix rouge qui
est créé des premières écoles
d'infirmières qui a défini tout le
diplôme d'infirmière qui est passé
aujourd'hui
il a d'abord été définis mis en place
par la croix rouge or ça date d'il ya
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années
mais suite à ça nous avons mis en place
des formations alors interne justement
de manière à ce que nos nos secouristes
soit en mesure de faire des gestes qu'il
faut de décrire la pause il le problème
qu'ils ont dans les yeux d'une manière
très précise un médecin du samu par
téléphone l'encadrement aucun cas moins
donc on se ne sont pas des médecins ou
des infirmiers mais ils sont en mesure
de gérer toute situation d'urgence et de
savoir la décrire pour prendre les aider
les spécialistes à prendre les décisions
qui doivent se présente évidemment le
découvrir à l'occasion de cette
exposition qui a lieu jusqu'à vendredi
en mairie d'elancourt consacré aux 150
ans de la croix rouge pour savoir toutes
les actions que mène la croix rousse
c'est juste avant les mots c'est une
seule une exposition très rond pendant
cinq ans alors qu'elle était elle était
la semaine dernière un home is and i l
est cette semaine à la mairie
d'elancourt elle sera en mai elle sera
moins à montigny-le-bretonneux et
enjoint elle passera trois semaines sur
trappe voisins le bretonneux et auteur
est mort et un numéro de téléphone et
adresse internet qui s'est affiché si
les gens veulent en savoir plus donc sur
cette exposition consacrée au sens aux
150 ans de la croix rouge et aussi pour
connaître toutes les actions que mène la
rouge et tous les projets on n'a pas le
temps d'en parler juste une seconde pour
l'âge même qu'ils sont intéressés à
payet pas que ça c'est que l'exposition
est agrémentée aussi d'une très jolie
collection de timbres sur la croix rouge
depuis 1914 et c'est vraiment un
complément de notre exposition que l'on
nous trouvons nous même très intéressant
donc expositions et expressions
notamment en même temps merci en tout
cas vous donne est revenu sur plateau de
cette actu merci beaucoup merci de votre
accueil
on va continuer à changer de sujet on
repart les environnements maintenant
coureurs à pied et écolo
la ronde des butineuses organisé ce
week-end à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines a accueilli la
cinquième édition de cette course qui
mêle les 10 km et marche nordique dont
l'objectif est de sensibiliser les
sportifs à la protection de
l'environnement
anthony rech
la ronde des butineuses une course à
travers la forêt pour alerter sur la
condition des abeilles ces petits
insectes si essentiel dans le cycle de
la pollinisation
mais exposée aux conséquences du
réchauffement climatique ne se regarde
sur ce que sur le péril de la bei
on s'aperçoit qu'en région parisienne en
fin de compte on est relativement peu
atteints par les maires le dit qu'il
veut et qui peuvent être retrouvés sur
les deux bayrou trouve énormément
diversité c'est ce qui fait la force de
certains de notre nature et de notre
environnement dans le cadre du projet
abeille sentinelle de l'environnement
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille cinq ruches dans sa
ferme pédagogique
après cinq éditions et de nombreuses
opérations de sensibilisation les
coureurs de la ronde des butineuses
deviennent de plus en plus écolo lors de
leurs foulées dans les bois la mentalité
a évolué parce qu'il ya de plus en plus
de travail de plus en plus de courses
nature et donc les gens on les
sensibilise à six a sérieusement sur ce
point là c'est surtout dans l'adn des
traileurs les autres coureurs ne sont
pas toujours très sensible on voit
beaucoup de coureurs prendre un gobelet
le jeter dans la nature prendre des
tubes de miel et les jeter dans la
nature ça c'est pas bon c'est
indispensable
d'ailleurs tous les trailer dégel or on
est en permanence sur eux
de plus en plus j'en vois de moins en
moins pardon sur le parcours maintenant
les gens sont vraiment mobilisés à tenir
compte vraiment la nature et des déchets
dans la nature
répartie sur quatre épreuves cette
cinquième édition de la ronde des
butineuses a accueilli 4 190
participants
allez un avant-goût de paquets à saint
cyr l'école avec une grande chasse aux
jeux aux oeufs sous les couleurs
américaines qui a réuni indiens et
cow-boys chapeau de cowboy sur la tête
colt à la ceinture il soufflait un petit
air de far west ce samedi à saint cyr à
l'école pas de ruée vers l'or mais une
chasse aux oeufs un peu particulière
pour les petits saint cyrien aujourd'hui
c'est une journée à 100% familles où les
parents viennent avec leurs enfants
participent au grand jeu des familles
s'ils le souhaitent sur inscription et
puis surtout accompagnent leurs enfants
dans les différents différents styles
stand stand de maquillage concours de
dessin ou balades à poney il y en avait
pour tous les âges
sous le regard des plus grands
personnages de western les enfants
puissent activer à chercher le précieux
butin mon stand et consiste en fait à
cacher des oeufs jaune
voilà et ils doivent les rechercher
comme un peu la chasse aux oeufs voilà
au western pas y en a ils sont en
surface et en plus en profondeur et
voilà on cherche vraiment à ce qu'ils
cherchent réellement l'oeuf une fois les
oeufs récolter les enfants les échange
contre un paquet de chocolats pour la
petite alix la journée a été fructueuse
le persil
au plus grand plaisir de son grand père
jean bernard qui l'accompagnent était
pourtant tvo et via profiter de la
recherche des oeufs dans le terrain
d'autres lots ont été réservées aux
gagnants des concours de la journée
les plus chanceux iront voir un dîner
spectacle sur le thème du far west à
disneyland paris
pendant près d'un mois nos journalistes
ont partagé le quotidien des motards de
la police nationale évinoise nous avons
voulu comprendre leurs multiples
missions car contrairement aux idées
reçues cette formation motocycliste
urbaine ne fait pas que des contrôles
routiers classiques en immersion avec
les motards de la police nationale c'est
toute cette semaine avec anthony rech
jonathan vilma et sandrine fontaine
c'est probablement l'une de leurs
activités les moins connus les
brigadiers de l'information
motocyclistes sont compétents pour les
contrôles de charge
cet après midi là une unité ce poste à
la sortie des mureaux en collaboration
avec la direction générale de
l'équipement d'île de france
l'objectif traquer les véhicules
surchargés et les temps de conduite des
professionnels de la route contrôle des
charges donc vérifier que les charges
réelles des véhicules dépassent pas les
fondations des cartophiles et puis
également au niveau du pouvoir terrestre
ait alors tout ce qui est temps de
conduite par une augmentation soit pas
réglementation sociale et transport
c'est pas que de la sécurité ce fils de
la réglementation par comprenez
transports
rapidement les policiers contrôlent un
véhicule tible à première vue ce camion
ne présente aucune anomalie
pourtant les brigadiers vont tout de
même vérifier les temps de conduite du
conducteur et ils s'aperçoivent que le
véhicule a circulé pendant près d'une
centaine de kilomètres sans carte dans
le chrono tachygraphe
dernier coup
en particulier et si dans
okello non c'est sûr le numéro numéro
a priori il n'y aurait pas de but de
fraude car la distance parcourue n'est
pas exceptionnel mais à charge de
l'entreprise de justifier devant la
justice compétente s'étendent conduite
non comptabilisés sur la carte du
chauffeur lors des contrôles de charge
il ya parfois des surprises comme ce
camion sur la balance l'écran affiche 3
2 800 kg pour un poids réglementaire
maximum de trois tonnes 5
il est donc trop lourd c'est fréquent
avec ces véhicules dont les entreprises
tentent de charger aux maximum pour
faire le minimum de course
mais à l'ouverture des portes on a des
petits camions qui sont classés encore
en tant que catégorie b donc voitures
sont fait 1 3 tonne sacs qui sont
équipés dario comme ceux qui manquent un
peu plus gros et le hayon dont ses
systèmes qui permet de monter et
descendre des palettes mais qui pèse
très lourd dans ce retour du coca camion
qui a déjà un poids à vide très élevé
j'avoue qu'il équipe pour porter très
très faibles alors beaucoup il n'y a pas
de ses moyens au canon alors qu'elle est
d'un maximum de son poids est une
entreprise qui crée avec ce type de
véhicule parce que si on change de
catégorie ont carrément chauffeur qu'il
va me falloir avoir introduit graf
twitter qui la carte
et donc une formation compliqué les
chaussures coûte plus cher tout coûte
plus cher que l'on est
c'est bizarre ce chauffeur repartira
finalement avec une simple amende pour
des pneumatiques trop usés en une après
midi les policiers ont contrôlé une
douzaine de véhicules
trois ont été sanctionnés et rendez vous
demain pour le deuxième épisode se 7,8
l'aktu est terminé merci de votre
attention
bonne soirée